can you tell the origin story of its
software
again one of the greatest game developer
companies ever it created wolfenstein 3d
games that define
my life also in many ways
as a thing that made me realize what
computers are capable of in terms of
graphics in terms of performance it just
unlocks something deep
um in me and understanding what these
machines are all about that's games can
do that so wolfenstein 3d doom quake
and uh just all the incredible
engineering innovation that went into
that so how did it all start
so i'll caveat upfront that i usually
don't consider myself the the historian
of the software side of things i usually
do
i kind of point people at john romero
for stories about the early days where
i you know i've never been like i've
commented that i'm a remarkably
unsentimental person in some ways where
i don't really spend a lot of time
unless i'm explicitly prodded to go back
and and think about the early days of
things and i didn't i
i didn't necessarily make the effort to
archive everything exactly in my brain
and the more that i work on machine
learning and ai and the aspects of
memory and how when you go back and
polish certain things it's not
necessarily exactly the way it happened
but you know having said all of that
from from my view the way everything
happened that led up to that was
uh after i was
an adult and kind of taking a few
college classes deciding to drop out i
was doing i was hard scrabble contract
programming work really struggling to
kind of keep groceries and pay my rent
and things
and the company that i was doing the
most work for was a company called soft
disk publishing which
had the sounds bizarre now business
model of monthly subscription software
you know before there was an internet
that people could connect to and get
software you would pay
you know a certain amount and every
month they would send you a disk that
had some random software on it and
people that were into computers thought
this was kind of cool and they had
different ones for the apple ii the the
2gs the pc the mac the uh amiga lots of
different things here so quirky little
business but i was doing a lot of
contract programming for them where i'd
write tiny little games and sell them
for 300 500
and one of the things that
that i was doing again to keep my head
above water here was i decided that i
could make one program and i could
port it to multiple systems so i would
write a game like dark designs or
catacombs and i would develop it on the
apple ii the 2gs and the ibm pc
which apparently was the thing that
really kind of piqued the attention of
the people working down there like jay
wilbur was my primary editor and tom
hall was a secondary editor and they
kept asking me it's like hey you should
come down and work for us here
and i i pushed it off a couple times
because i was really enjoying my freedom
of kind of being off on my own even if i
was barely getting by i loved it i was
doing nothing but programming all day
but i did have enough close scrapes with
like damn i'm just really out of money
that maybe i should um get an actual job
rather than contracting these kind of
one at a time things and and jay wilbur
was great he was like fedexing me the
checks when i would need them i to kind
of get over whatever hump i was at
so i took the i finally took him up on
their offer to come down to shreveport
louisiana i was in kansas city at the
time
drove down
to through the ozarks and everything
down to louisiana and saw the soft disk
offices went through talked to a bunch
of people met the people i had been
working with remotely at that time
but the most important thing for me was
i met two programmers there john romero
and lane roth that for the first time
ever i had met programmers that knew
more cool stuff than i did where
the world was just different back then i
was in kansas city it was one of those
smartest kid in the school does all the
computer stuff the teachers don't have
anything to teach him but all i had to
learn from was these few books at the
library it was not much at all and there
were some aspects of programming that
were kind of black magic to me like it's
like oh he knows how to format a track
on i am you know on a low-level drive
programming
interface and this was i was still not
at all sure i was going to take the job
but i met these awesome programmers that
were doing cool stuff and romero had
worked at origin systems and he had done
like you know so many different games
ahead of time
that i did kind of quickly decides like
yeah i'll go take the job down there
and
i
settled down there moved in and started
working on more little projects and the
first kind of big change that happened
down there was the company wanted to
make a gaming focused a pc gaming
focused subscription uh just like all
their others the same formula that they
used for everything
pay a monthly fee and you'll get
a disc with one or two games just every
month and no choice in what you get but
we think it'll be fun and that was the
model they were comfortable with and
said all right we're going to start this
gamer's edge department and
all of us that were interested in that
like me romero i'm tom hall was kind of
helping us from from his side of things
jay would peek in and we had a few other
programmers
uh working with us at the time and we
were going to to just start making games
just the same model i am and we dived in
and it was fantastic you know we have to
make new games every month every month
yeah and this in retrospect looking back
at it that sense that i had done all
this contract programming and john
romero had done like far more of this
where he had done one of his teaching
himself efforts was he made a game for
every letter of the alphabet it's that
sense of like i'm just going to go make
26 different games give them a different
theme and you learn so much when you go
through and you cr crank these things
out like on a bi-weekly monthly basis
something starts to finish so it's not
like a night just an idea it's not just
from from the very beginning to the very
end
it's done it has to be done there's no
delaying it's done and you've got
deadlines and that kind of uh
rapid iteration pressure cooker
environment was super important for all
of us developing the skills that i you
know that brought us to where we
eventually went to i mean people would
say like like in the history of the
beatles like it wasn't them being the
beatles it was them playing all of these
other uh you know early works that that
opportunity to craft all of their skills
before they were famous that was very
critical to their later successes and i
think there's a lot of that here where
we did these games that nobody remembers
uh lots of little things that
contributed to building up the skill set
for the things that eventually did make
us famous
yeah dostoevsky wrote the gambler
i had to write it in a month
just make money
and nobody remembers that probably
because he had to figure out because
it's literally
he didn't have enough time to write it
fast enough so to come up with hacks
actually literally but it again comes
down to that point where pressure and
limitation of resources is surprisingly
important and it's counterintuitive in a
lot of ways where you just think that if
you've got all the time in the world and
you've got all the resources in the
world of course you're going to get
something better but sometimes it really
does work out that the you know
innovations mother necessity and you
know where you can or resource
constraints and you have to do things
when you don't have a choice
it's surprising what you can do is there
any good games written in that time
would you say some of them are still fun
to go back and play where you get the
they were they were all about kind of
the more modern term is game feel about
how just the exact feel that things it's
not the grand strategy of the design but
how running and jumping and shooting and
those things i feel in the in the moment
and some of those are still if you sat
down at them you kind of go it's a
little bit different it doesn't have the
same movement feel but you move over and
you're like bang jump bang it's like hey
that's kind of cool still so you can get
lost in the rhythm of the game like the
is that what you mean by feel
just like uh there's something about it
that pulls you in
nowadays again people talk about
compulsion loops and things where it's
that i am that sense of exactly what
you're doing what your fingers are doing
on the keyboard what your eyes are
seeing and there are going to be these
sequences of things grab the loot shoot
the monster jump over the obstacle get
to the end of the level these are
eternal aspects of game design in a lot
of ways but there are better and worse
ways to do all of them and we did so
many of these games that it was i we got
a lot of practice with it so
one of the kind of weird things that was
happening at this time is john romero
was getting some uh some strange fan
mail and back in the days this is before
email so we literally got letters
sometimes and telling him it's like oh i
want to talk to you about your games i
want to
reach out different things
and
eventually it turned out that these were
all coming from scott miller at apogee
software
and he was reaching out through he
didn't think he could contact john
directly that he would get intercepted
so he was trying to get him to contact
him through like back channel fan mail
because he basically was saying hey i'm
making all this money on shareware games
i want you to make shareware games
because he had seen some of the the
games that romero had done
and
you know we looked at uh scott miller's
games and we didn't think they were very
good i am we're like that can't be
making the kind of money that he's
saying he's making 10 grand or something
i am off of this game and we really
thought that he was full of [ __ ] that it
was a lie trying to get
to get him into this but so that was
kind of going on at i am you know at one
level he was
and it was funny the moment when romero
realized that he had some of these
letters pinned up on his wall of like
all of his fans and then we noticed that
they all had the same return address
with different names on them which was a
little bit of a two-edged sword there
trying to figure out the puzzle laid off
yeah out before perform yeah what
happened after i kind of coincident with
that was i was working on a lot of the
new technologies where
uh i was now full on the ibm pc for the
first time where i was really a long
hold out on apple ii forever and i've
you know i loved my apple too it was the
computer i always wished i had when i
was growing up and when i finally did
have one i was i was kind of clinging on
to that well past it sort of good used
by the best computer ever made would you
say
um
i wouldn't make judgments like that
about it but it was positioned in such a
way especially in the school systems
that it impacted a whole lot of american
programmers at least where there was
programs that the apple ii's got into
the schools and they had enough
capability that lots of interesting
things happened with them you know in
europe it was different you had your
amigas and ataris and you know um acorns
in the uk and things that that had
different things but in the united
states it was probably the apple ii made
the most impact for
a lot of programmers of my generation
but so i was really digging into the ibm
and this was even more so with the total
focus because i had moved to another
city where i didn't know anybody that i
wasn't working with uh i had a little
apartment and then at soft disk again
the things that that drew me to it i had
a couple programmers that knew more than
i did uh and they had a library they had
a set of books and a set of magazines
they had a couple years of magazines the
old dr dobbs journal and all of these
magazines that had
information about things and so
i was just in total immersion mode it
was eat breathe sleep computer
programming particularly the ibm for
everything that i was doing and i was
digging into a lot of these low-level
hardware details that people weren't
usually paying attention to the way the
the ibm ega cards worked
which was fun for me i hadn't had
experience with things at that level and
back then you could get hardware
documentation just down at the register
levels this is where the crtc register
is this is how the the color registers
work and how the different things are
applied and they were designed for a
certain reason they were designed for an
application they were had an intended
use in mind but i was starting to look
at uh other ways that they could perhaps
be exploited that they weren't initially
intended for because you're coming on
like
first of all what operating system was
there what what instruction set was it
like what what what are the
what are we talking about so this was
dawson x86 so 16-bit uh 8086 the 286s
were there and 386's existed they were
rare uh we had a couple for our
development systems but uh we were still
targeting the more broad i
it was all dos 16 bit um none of this
was kind of dos extenders and things how
different is it from the systems of
today's it's kind of a precursor that's
similar very little if you open up
command.exe
on or com on windows you see some of the
remnants of all of that but it was a
different world it was the 640k is
enough world and nothing was protected
it crashed all the time you had tsrs or
terminate and stay resident hacks on top
of things that would cause configuration
problems all the hardware was manually
configured in your auto exec so it was a
very different world but the code is
still the same similar you would say you
could still write my earliest code there
was written in pascal that was what i
had learned i am kind of an earlier
point so between basic and c plus plus
there's pascal so when basic assembly
language and some of my
yeah my intermediate stuff was well you
had to for performance basic was just
too slow so most of the work that i was
doing as a contract programmer in my
teenage years was uh was assembly
language but then i wrote games in
assembly yeah complete games in uh in
assembly language
and it's thousands and thousands of
lines of three-letter acronyms for the
the instructions that's you don't earn
the once again greatest programmer ever
label without being able to eradicate an
assembly okay but that's again everybody
wrote there everybody sirius wrote their
games in assembly language it was kind
of serious you see what he said yeah
everybody's serious yeah it was an
outlier to use uh pascal a little bit
where there was one famous program
called wizardry it was like one of the
great early role-playing games that was
written in pascal but it was almost
nothing used pascal there but i did
learn pascal and i remember doing all of
my like to this day i sketch in data
structures when i'm thinking about
something i'll you know i'll i'll open
up a file and i'll start writing struct
definitions for how data is going to be
laid out and pascal was kind of
formative to that because i remember
designing my rpgs in pascal record
structures and things like that and so i
had i've gotten a pascal compiler for
the apple 2gs that i could work on and
the first ibm game that i developed i
did in pascal and and that's actually
kind of an interesting story again
talking about the constraints and
resources where i had an apple 2gs i
didn't have an ibm pc i wanted to port
my applications to ibm because i thought
i could make more money on it so what i
wound up doing is i rented a pc for a
week
and bought a copy of turbo pascal and so
i had a hard one week and this was
cutting into what minimal profit margin
i had there but i had this computer for
a week i had to get my program ported
before i had to return the pc
yeah and that was kind of what the first
thing that i had done on the ibm pc and
what led me to the taking the job at
soft disk and turbo pascal
uh how's that different from regular
pascal is a different compiler or
something like that so it was uh it was
a product of borland which before
microsoft kind of killed them they were
they were the hot stuff developer tools
company you had borland turbo pascal and
turbo c and pro prologue i mean all the
different things but what they did was
they took a supremely pragmatic approach
of making something useful it was one of
these great examples where pascal was an
academic language and you had things
like the ucsdp system that wizardry was
actually written in that they did they
did manage to make a game with that but
it was
not a super practical system while turbo
pascal was it was called turbo because
it was blazingly fast to compile i mean
really ridiculously 10 to 20 times
faster than most other compilers at the
time but it also had very pragmatic
access to look you can just poke at the
hardware in these different ways and we
have libraries that let you do things
and it was a pretty good it was a
perfectly good way to write games and
this is one of those things where people
have talked about
different paths that computer
development could have taken where c
took over the world for uh reasons that
came out of unix and eventually linux
and
and that was not a foregone conclusion
at all and people can make
real reasoned rational arguments that
the world might have been better if it
had gone a pascal route i'm somewhat
agnostic on that where i do know from
experience it was perfectly good enough
to do do that and it had some
fundamental improvements like it had
range checked arrays as an option there
which could avoid many of c's real
hazards that happened in a security
space
but c1 they were basically operating at
about the same level of abstraction it
was a systems programming language but
visa pascal had more emphasis on data
structures i actually i um in the in the
tree of languages dipascal come before
sea
did it they were prior contemporaneous
so pascal's lineage went to modula 2 and
eventually oberon which was another
nicholas word
kind of experimental language but they
were all good enough at that level now
some of the classic academic-oriented
pascals were just missing fundamental
things like oh you can't access this
core system thing because we're just
using it to teach students but turbo
pascal showed that only modest changes
to it really did make it a completely
capable language and it had some reasons
why you could implement it as a single
pass compiler so it could be way way
faster although less scope for
optimizations if you do it that way uh
and it did have some range checking
options it had a little bit better
typing capability you'd have properly
typed enum sorts of things and other
stuff that c lacked but you know c was
also clearly good enough and it wound up
with a huge inertia from the unix
ecosystem and everything
with that garbage collection no it was
not garbage collected same kind of thing
same manual so you could still have your
use after freeze and all those other
problems but over um just getting rid of
array overruns at least if you were
compiled with that debugging option
certainly would have avoided a lot of
problems and could have a lot of
benefits but so anyways that was the
next thing i had to learn c because c
was where it seemed like most of the
most of the things were going so i
abandoned pascal and i started working
in c i started hacking on these hardware
things dealing with i you know the
graphics controllers and the ega systems
and what we most wanted to do so at that
time we had
uh we were sitting in our darkened
office playing all the the different
console video games we're figuring out
what do we want to kind of what games do
we want to make for our gamer's edge
product there and so we had one of the
one of the first super nintendo's
sitting there and we had an older
nintendo we were looking at all those
games and the core thing that those
consoles did that you just didn't get on
the pc games was this ability to have a
massive scrolling world where most of
the games that you would make on the pc
uh and early earlier personal computers
would be a static screen you move little
things around on it
and you interact like that maybe you go
to additional screens as you know as you
move but arcade games and consoles had
this wonderful ability to just have a
big world that you're slowly moving your
window through and that was for those
types of games the kind of action
exploration adventure games that was a
super super important thing
and pc games just didn't do that
and what i had had come across was a
couple different techniques for
implementing that on the pc and they're
not
hard complicated things when i explain
them now they're they're they're pretty
straightforward but just nobody was
doing you sound like einstein describing
his five papers is pretty
straightforward i understand but it
they're nevertheless revolutionary so
size scrolling is a game changer yeah
it's scrolling genius invention or
vertical and right and some of the
consoles had different limitations about
you could do one but not the other and i
and there were similar things going on
as advancements even in the console
space where you'd have like the original
mario game was uh like just horizontal
scrolling and then later mario games
added vertical aspects to it and
different things that uh that you were
doing to explore you know kind of expand
the capabilities there and so much of
the early game design for decades was
removing limitations letting you do
things that you envisioned as a designer
you wanted the player to experience but
the hardware just couldn't really uh or
you didn't know how to make it happen it
felt impossible you can imagine that you
want to create a like this big world
through which you can side scroll like
through which you can walk
uh and then you ask yourself a question
how do i actually build that in a way
that's uh
like the the latency is low enough
uh the hardware can actually deliver
that in such a way there's a compelling
yeah and we knew what we wanted to do
because we were we were playing all of
these console games playing all these
nintendo games and arcade games clearly
there was a whole world of awesome
things there that we just couldn't do on
the pc at least initially
uh because every programmer can tell
it's like if you want to scroll you can
just redraw the whole screen but then it
turns out well you're going five frames
per second i feel that's not an
interactive fun experience you want to
be going 30 or 60 frames per second or
something and it just didn't feel like
that was possible it felt like the pcs
had to get five times faster for you to
make a playable game there
and interestingly i wound up with two
completely different solutions for the
scrolling problem and this is i'm
this is a theme that runs through
everything where all of these big
technical advancements it turns out
there's always a couple different ways
of doing them and it's not like you
found the one true way of doing it and
we'll see this as we go into 3d games
and things later but so the scrolling
the first set of scrolling tricks that i
got was
there was the hardware had this ability
to uh you could shift like inside the
window of memory i am so the ega cards
at the time had 256 kilobytes of memory
and it was awkwardly set up in this
planar format where uh instead of having
256 or you know 24 million colors you
had 16 colors which is four bits so you
had four bit planes 64k a piece of
course 64k is a nice round number for
16-bit addressing so your graphics card
had a 16-bit window that you could look
at and you could tell it to start the
video scan out anywhere inside there so
there were a couple games that had taken
this approach if you could make a 2x2
screen or a 1x4 screen and you could do
scrolling really easily like that you
could just lay it all out and just pan
around there but you just couldn't make
it any bigger because that's all the
memory that was there
uh the first insight to the scrolling
that i had was well if we make a screen
that's just one tile larger you know in
the we usually had tiles that were 16
pixels by 16 pixels the little classic
mario block that you run into lots of
art gets drawn that way and your screen
is a certain number of tiles but if you
had one little buffer region
outside of that you could easily pan
around inside that 16 pixel region that
could be perfectly smooth but then what
happens if you get to the edge and you
want to keep going
the first way we did scrolling was what
i called adaptive tile refresh which was
really just a matter of you get to the
edge and then you go back to the
original point and then only change the
tiles that have actually that are
different between where it was in most
of the games at the time if you think
about sort of your classic super mario
brothers game you've got big fields of
blue sky uh
long rows of the same brick texture
and there's a lot of commonality it's
kind of like a data compression thing if
you take the screen and you set it down
on top of each other in general only
about 10 of the tiles were actually
different there
so this was a way to
go ahead and say well i'm going to move
it back and then i'm only going to
change those 10 20 uh whatever percent
tiles there and that meant that it was
essentially five times faster than if
you were redrawing all of the tiles and
that worked well enough for us to do a
bunch of these games for i am for
gamer's edge we had a lot of these
scrolling games like slournax and shadow
knights and things like that that we
were cranking out at this high rate that
had this scrolling effect on it
and it worked well enough there were
design challenges there where if you
made the worst case if you made a
checkerboard over the entire screen you
scroll over one and every single tile
changes and your frame rate's now five
frames per second because it had to
redraw everything so the designers had a
little bit that they had to worry about
they had to make these relatively plain
looking levels but it was still pretty
magical it was something that we hadn't
seen before
and
uh the first thing that we wound up
doing with that was i had just gotten
this working and tom hall was sitting
there with me and we were looking over
at our super nintendo on the side there
with super mario 3 running and we had
the technology we had the tools set up
there and we stayed up all night and we
basically cloned the first level of
super mario brothers performance-wise as
well yeah and so it and we had our
little character running and jumping in
there it was you know it wasn't
uh it was close to pixel accurate as far
as all the uh the backgrounds and
everything but the gaming was just stuff
that we cobbled together from previous
games that i had written i just kind of
like really kit-bashed the whole thing
together to make this demo and that was
one of the rare cases when i said i i
don't usually do these all-night
programming things there's probably only
two memorable ones that i can think
about you know one was the all-nighter
to go ahead and get i am to get our
dangerous dave and copyright
infringement is how we titled it because
we had a game called dangerous dave was
you know running around with the shotgun
shooting things uh and we were just
taking our most beloved game at the time
there the super mario 3 and sort of
sticking dave inside that with this new
scrolling technology that was going
perfectly smooth for
i am you know for them
as it ran and tom and i just kind of
literally the next morning you know kind
of left and we left a disc on i you know
on the desk for john romero and jay
wilbur to see and just said run this
and we eventually made it back in later
in the day and it was you know like they
grabbed us and pulled us in you know
pulled us into the room and that was the
point where they were like we got to do
something with this you know we're we're
going to make a company we're going to
go make our own games where this was
something that
we were able to just kind of hit them
with a hammer of an experience like wow
this is just like so much cooler than
what we thought was possible there and
initially we tried to get nintendo to to
let us make super mario 3 on the pc
that's really what we wanted to do we're
like hey we can finish this it's line of
sight for this will be great
and
we sent something to nintendo and we
heard that it did get looked at in japan
and they just weren't interested in that
i but that's another one of those life
could have gone a very different way
where we could have been like nintendo's
house pc team
you know at that point and define the
direction of
you know uh
wolfenstein and uh
doom and quake could have been a
nintendo creation yeah so at the same
time that we were just doing our first
scrolling demos um we reached out to
scott miller at apogee and said it's
like hey we do want to make some games
you know these things that you think you
want those are those are nothing what do
you see what we can actually do now this
is going to be amazing
and he just like popped right up and
sent a check to us where we at that
point we still thought he might be a
fraud that he was just lying about all
of this but he was totally correct on
how much money he was making with his
shareware titles
and this was his his kind of real
brainstorm about this where shareware
was this idea that software doesn't have
a fixed price if you use it you send out
of the goodness of your heart some money
to the creator and there were a couple
utilities that did make some significant
success like that but for the most part
it didn't really work you know there
wasn't much software in a pure shareware
model that that was successful the
apogee innovation was to take something
call it shareware split it into three
pieces you always made a trilogy
and you would put the first piece out
but then you buy the whole trilogy for
some shareware amount
which in reality it meant that the first
part was a demo where you kind of like
the demo went everywhere for free and
you paid money to to get the whole set
but it was still played as shareware and
we were happy to have the first one go
everywhere and it wasn't a crippled demo
where the first episode of all these
trilogies it was a real complete game
and probably 20 times as many people
played that part of it thought they had
a great game had found fond memories of
it but never paid us a dime but enough
people were happy with that where it was
really quite successful at these early
games that we didn't think very much of
compared to commercial quality games but
they were doing really good business
some fairly crude things and people
it was good business people enjoyed it
and it wasn't like you were taking a
crap shoot on what you were getting you
just played a third of the experience
and you loved it enough to hand write
out a check and put it in an envelope
and address it and send it out to apogee
to uh to get the rest of them so it was
a really pretty feel-good business
prospect there because everybody was
happy you know they knew what they were
getting i am when they send it in and
they would send in fan mail if you're
going to the trouble of addressing a
letter and i'm you know filling out an
envelope you write something in it and
there were just the literal bags of fan
mail for the shareware um games so
people loved them i should mention that
for you the definition of wealth is
being able to
have pizza whenever you want for me
there was a dream
because i would play shareware games
over and over the the part that's free
over and over and it was very deeply
fulfilling experience but you know i i
dreamed of a time when i could actually
afford the full experience and this is
kind of this dreamland beyond beyond the
horizon when
you could you could find out what else
is there in some sense
even just playing the shareware was um
it's the limitation of that
you know life is is limited eventually
we all die in that way shareware was
like
somehow really fulfilling to have this
kind of mysterious thing beyond
what's free
always there it's kind of
i don't know that was maybe it's because
a part of my childhood just playing sure
games that was a really fulfilling
experience it's so interesting how that
model still brought joy to so many
people yeah that's 20x people that
played it yeah i felt very good about
that i would run into people it's like
that would say oh i love that game you
know that you had early on commander
keane whatever and
um and no they they meant just the first
episode that they got to see everywhere
the crap out of commander and that was
that was all good yeah
yeah but so we were in this position
where scott miller was just fronting us
cash and saying yeah make you know make
a game
but
i we did not properly pull the trigger
and say all right we're going to we're
quitting our jobs we were like we're
going to do both we're going to keep
working at soft disk working on this and
then we're going to go ahead and make a
new game for apogee at the same time
and this eventually did lead to some
legal problems and we had we had trouble
it all got worked out in the end but it
was not a good call at the time there
and your legal mind at the time was not
stellar
you you were not thinking uh in terms of
in legal no i i definitely wasn't none
of us were uh
and in hindsight yeah it's like how did
we think we were going to get away with
like even using our work computers to
write right software for you know our
our breakaway uh new company it was not
a good plan
you